this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah well thank you very much thanks for
inviting me and it's really nice to be
back here and see so many familiar faces
I'm going to tell you today about a
research project that I have been
working on in Beltsville for a little
while and and the titles here basically
we wanted to look at how microbial
systems respond to the application of
glyphosate in a variety of farming
systems so our objectives are to compare
factors in modern carp farming systems
or cropping systems that impact soil
microbial communities plant microbe
interactions and plant health now this
modern soil cropping systems that's like
political code word for systems that use
a whole range of technologies including
glyphosate and Roundup Ready technology
GMO technology so USDA monitors
herbicides that are that are registered
by the EPA we monitor them regularly and
a lot of times will initiate experiments
based on comments that are sent in to
the secretary from from constituents and
there was in the in the last well 15
years or so the secretary has been
getting a lot of mail about glyphosate
and some concerns about privacy so just
a really quick review glyphosate is a
compound that blocks the Shakima Cassatt
pathway and this pathway is is
critically important for amino acid
production as well as a bunch of
secondary compound production the
Roundup Ready gene is a bypass for that
blockage so if you apply glyphosate and
you have the Roundup Ready gene you can
how the system basically works and it
was the first herbicide GMO system that
was packaged in the US
so it's a very popular compound it's
applied to about 90 percent of 98
percent of the corn and soybean in the
US and that's in the 90 or so 95 million
acres of each of those depending on the
year so you can see that there's a fair
amount of it applied to the landscape
and so we're very interested in what the
impact of this may be in the large scale
and you can see over time the popularity
and the use of it has increased is the
proportional use of glyphosate among
many different types of pesticides so
there's been some issues about the
impact that was like to say for a number
of years then you've probably heard
about some of them herbicide resistance
is a big one and this map here below has
has six panels starting in 2002 going to
2012 in which it shows the the states
that have the number of glyphosate
resistant plant species in the states
and you can see that it's like it's
increasing year by year or two - year by
year oh sorry there's um there's some
concern that there's a there's a yield
hit when glyphosate is applied and this
may be a function of multiple mechanisms
and that that is an area of research
that's being conducted right now and the
main thing that we're gonna focus on
here is the effects on plant disease
ecology and really really just looking
at some of the organisms that might be
responsible for diseases and not
necessarily doing a pathological
screening of these of these cracker
plants so there's been a lot of debate
about this impact of glyphosate on plant
diseases and and there and these are
just a few titles from papers papers
that talk about the effects in the
rhizosphere interactive mostly
interaction with rhizosphere compounds
as well as interaction with metals in
the in the soil manganese as a was an
issue and then there's been some sort of
rebuttals to that talking about the this
paper is mostly based on the
stoichiometry of application and how
much actual
you add to the soil relative to the
amount of other things in the soil and
this this is pretty well done study so
there's been a lot of debate out there
and we were partially because of well
and one of the main figures that was
constantly referred to was this figure
from Kramer and means trims up out in
Purdue and this this study would they
have produced many figures that look
like this you apply glyphosate at at
time zero and within say 40 days 50 days
you have significantly more Fusarium
colonies growing cerium is a wilt
disease that's that's that's fairly
ubiquitous in cropping systems but in
this case the claim was that these type
of user was was pathogenic and was
building up in the soil in all of these
millions and millions of acres of corn
and soybean so we were asked to sort of
review some of this literature and look
back at the at what was done to try to
that that came to these conclusions and
and asked this question if see if we
could revisit this question does a does
the application like shift the
composition and function of the soil of
the of the root end of soil microbes
does the presence of the Roundup Ready
gene in a crop cause a shift in the
microbial community associated with and
does the legacy of glyphosate
application like and we we decide on
plus ten year greater than ten years
does that contribute to the differences
in route associated microorganisms so we
did we did this study at multiple
locations and looking at both bacteria
fungi and in a sub experiment nematodes
but I'm just going to focus on the fungi
and this is a picture of Fusarium
forming
okay so we're we did this experiment or
the site I'm going to talk about today
is the USDA Beltsville farming systems
project and it's one of only it's one of
just a few long-term farming systems
projects in this in the country that
compare some sort of conventional
tillage a no tillage and organic systems
all at the same site and all that we're
sort of experimentally designed to be
compared this is in the Chesapeake Bay
watershed so many of the issues related
to Chesapeake Bay eutrophication are
applicable to the practices that we
carry out here and so we abide by the
phosphorus standards that have been
implemented by Maryland State as well as
any EPA or national standards these
plots were established in 1996 and the
field was no-till for 11 years before
that so they did no-till to try to sort
of normalize things and then impose
these these plots the way it's laid out
we did a I didn't do it I was here at
the time but they they did a very an
extensive spatial survey of this whole
entire field and based on physical and
biochemical attributes of block this out
Laurie did you were you did you help in
doing this
initially with dr. raping horse from
Laurie has helped over over over time so
I wasn't sure done by dr. Ravin horses
University of Maryland and this is how
how we decided or they decide to block
it out and this is what the farm looks
like there's like slight rolling hills
this is a wheat crop here that's a major
highway right back there the plots are
30 feet wide and 390 feet long we we use
full-size tractors and and 10-foot
implement 10-foot wide implements to
plant where we actually got a 30 foot
planter now we're going to plant in one
one run now and so that's just a kind of
a view of what
looks like so so I'm gonna I'm gonna
sort of zoom into this area to show you
the plot layout so you get an idea of
how the experiment was designed so we
have we're in this what I'm talking
about today I'm going to be comparing
four different systems no-till system
and a chisel tool system they both are
three-year rotation corn soybean wheat
mineral fertilizer and herbicides and
there's two organic systems either a
three-year or a six year rotation the
three years corn soybean wheat and then
a hairy vetch and the six years corn
soybean wheat and then it goes into
three years of alfalfa and they both
have legume animal manure and we use
cultural practices to suppress weeds so
if we zoom in on this is just rep three
what you'll see is the different systems
that we have compared here every system
is composed of subplots and the reason
we have subplots there is because we
have every phase present every year so
corn soybean wheat for a three-year
rotation and then now FAL I mean in the
six year rotation we'd have corn soybean
wheat alfalfa alfalfa alfalfa and so we
can compare any phase of the rotation
and control for all the weather for that
particular year which is nice and that
will come into play a little bit later
I'm not going to be talking about the
organic to system today and that's kind
of like a foil it's really a bad system
because corn soybean corn soybean and
it's terrible it's really good at
producing weed seeds so within these
plots I set up micro plots and what we
have to pay attention here and I fail to
leave again
but these three micro plots right here
is what we're looking at today we have a
a Roundup Ready corn genotype that's
sprayed a Roundup Ready corn genotype
that's not sprayed and a in a isoline of
the Roundup Ready corn so it's the same
exact genotype but just without the RR
gene in it and then we have the same
thing for soybean we have the Roundup
Ready soybean sprayed not sprayed and
then the isoline and so when
we're comparing sprayed and not sprayed
we can control for time in the season by
comparing the sprayed and the not
sprayed of the same genotype that have
that have sort of moved through time
together and then as a secondary
comparison we can compare the Roundup
Ready genotype to the isoline to get at
whether or not the single gene in there
is making any difference so this is just
a close-up to show you those those those
plots they're 30 the main plots are 30
feet wide 390 feet long we did that
every the micro plots are 10 feet wide
by 20 feet long and we harvested the
middle two rows so we we we looked at
corn and soybean here to heart we
harvested 15 centimeter monoliths at two
dates of vegetative 5 and reproductive -
so we basically a vegetative 5 we
sampled and then spray glyphosate and
then about 25 days later at R 2 we came
in and did this again so we have right
before glyphosate is applied and then 25
days after glyphosate is applied and
that was done for each crop each genus
type and for monoliths per plot and of
course that was replicated so we
isolated bulk and rhizosphere soils we
we broke the bulk soil away and then
brushed the rhizosphere soil we played
it at we wash them or wash them snip
them and then we actually surface
sterilized them and then plated them out
to on Kumada selective media and select
the media for Fusarium and this part
here is really replicating what was done
in the literature and then we we did a
lot of soil biochemistry phospholipid
fatty acids and we did sequencing on 16s
and i TS sequencing we did some
additional analysis which I'll talk
a little bit later and this some of this
is ongoing and then with the plants we
also did some plant biochemistry yield
and and did some of some more specific
sort of analysis of symbiotic bacteria
so folks so looking at the at the a
plating score so we scored over 6100
root segments we ID'd over 2,400
colonies my lab was just like it just
was full of plates it was kind of fun to
go back and do this and then we kept
coming up with usual suspects based on
morphology so we would we would streak
them out onto minimal media to try to
make them saw relate and while we were
do while we were doing that we would
sequence the IDS regime of different
moral types we did about 384 individual
i TS sequencing to come up with these
eleven taxa which were sort of the usual
suspects and this non sporulating one is
was some fungi we couldn't get to spoil
eight it would just grow on this minimal
media and and we just we're trying to
figure out what it is actually so so
here's a here's the results what we have
here is corn on the top row here
2013-2014 soy on the bottom row
2013-2014 where you see an s that means
that the sorry let me step back and then
this is comparing the blue is the
isoline that's right Blue is isoline the
gray is the Roundup Ready genotype
without spray and the Green is the
Roundup Ready genotype with spray where
you see an S
that means the spray was significant so
it was a significant increase here when
we sprayed if you see a RR that means
that the gene had an effect in this case
it we it went down this is fairly
significant where you see a C that means
it's comparison between the blue bar and
the green bar that means the combination
of the spray and the genotype is
significant
really what I see here is just messiness
and while we were doing this my my whole
crew is saying to me why why are we
doing this it's really hard to ID a few
Serie more macro Femina just from
morphology and we're going through and
and and doing hundreds and hundreds of
samples like this and and probably some
of the mess in here is miss I being
these very similar-looking fungi and I
said well what we're doing is we're
looking for that we're looking for this
response we're trying to see if when we
repeated their experiments if we see
this and and our data our data doesn't
support this basically we see see some
random are not random but inconsistent
times when we saw a significant growth
and we would we described us as pretty
stochastic growth in in the sense of we
would see colonies here not not there
and we had lots of replicates to to try
to flesh this out so our data doesn't
support this exactly and we wanted to to
look at things in addition to just a few
cerium so we ID'd of these all these
other taxa and started looking started
looking at them from the standpoint of
okay well we have this consortium of
organisms here do we see any
relationship among the among the
organisms even if we're if it's not in
response to the treatments and then one
thing that popped out and this was very
clear looking at the plates is that
Fusarium and macro Femina seem to
co-occur together and the other thing is
that
trichoderma seemed antagonistic to
Fusarium and a few others but then in
some cases it it had a positive
correlation as well but in the organic
and no-till Trichoderma seem fairly
antagonistic to a number of different
organisms
so here's the here's a picture of
Fusarium tended to be positively
correlated with macro Femina Trichoderma
typical green spores looked like it was
antagonistic to a number of of different
taxa so if we so we moving on to the
sequencing part of this project we
wanted to use the same exact samples
that we used for the route culturing
work to then extract DNA from the
sequences in and DNA from the samples in
attempt to assemble a reflection of the
composition of the microbial community
so I'm gonna go through this and it's a
lot of words but but it might be very
important to some people in the audience
so I'll just go through this real quick
so we looked at we used my seat platform
and we looked at 1150 two separate
samples over 28 plates so we use full
plates so that's that's that gives you
an idea of how deep we sequenced we used
we trim the ends using cut adapt some of
these are fairly new programs and data
to was used to filter the ends and infer
sequence variants so the reason I'm
pointing this out is we're not we're not
taking the sequences and trying to align
them to a big database and say what see
what species are these we're using
probability to say the this sequence
occurred so many times in my in my data
that it's probably real even if NCBI or
some database doesn't have a copy of
that and so we're determining sequence
variants by probability and not whether
it's been ID'd before or its similarity
to something that's been ID'd before and
I think that's that's that's kind of
where this field is going because we
realized we don't we haven't surveyed
everything yet and so it doesn't make
sense to throw out all that variation
and just keep finding ourselves in two
clusters or groups that have been
commonly identified we brought this data
into a file a seek and and created some
some tax on phylogenetic trees and then
use that information to create
ordinations within this dc2 program you
can you can run permanent OVAs and we
thought that was a very important thing
especially in a study like this where we
have multiple environmental factors and
we want to try to tease out which ones
are playing the most important role and
then we plotted this out ggplot and our
and and the and all of this work here we
host on a github github site so that
that's a public repository for for data
data analysis and we basically put all
our scripts up there so when we publish
this you'll be able to go get our data
and our send our program and rerun
everything you you want to or tweak it
the way you think you might so it's very
very much will be publicly available
okay so looking at this the sequence
data here is a rarefaction curve of all
of the wells and this is just to give
you idea of the variance among all the
whole experiment we sequence three
hundred paired
three hundred base prepared in fragments
and generated about 129 million reads
with a read count of a hundred and
twelve per sample we identified between
now this is this is actually calling go
to use but we identified between 800 and
680 use in here when when you look at
the the rarefaction measure based on the
system's
there's no significant difference among
among the systems so this is a everyone
or not everyone but a lot of people have
seen these recently there's a
distribution of the dominant fungal tax
in the farming systems project and see
conventional tale
no-till organic three and organic six so
if you look at it right off the bat you
see well they I actually I won't tell
you what I think of these but uh you can
see differences here between in the
organic systems there's some differences
here there's there's some things that
stand out really clearly like this is
present in the no-till and N and not as
much in the others and then this one in
particular is president organic three
and is just in organic so what are these
this is a abba city of my seats a little
puffball these are these are all
saprophytic organisms this this
particular organism produces a lot of
phenol oxidases and actually produces
lipases this piezo Sally's you've
probably seen these out in the field if
you work if you ever work out in the
field in corn or soybean field this we
all we've really only saw orphan
mainly in the organic systems I think
this is I think I think this is
interesting that that there are that
there are organisms that seem sort of
dominant in organic systems as opposed
to conventional systems these these
systems receive poultry litter there are
different inputs so it's very hard to
sort of just sect out exactly what could
be influencing these but we're we're
gonna follow up on this and then here
this this s cotija is a leaf is a leaf
lesion and what's very what's
interesting about this is it seems to
come on late in the season so no one
really focuses on it as a pathogen but
you can see it all over that's a bean
plant and it infects wheat as well and
people have thought that it really
doesn't do much because it comes on
right towards the ends of end of seed
fill but I wonder though if if some
organisms that we see appear late in the
season like that are not actually
Leighton organisms that are impacting
the the growth of these of these crops
and may be more highly abundant in some
systems rather than others so if we want
to look at the structure of the fungal
community generally what we'll do is is
develop distance matrices and in this
case we've done that and plotted them
using n DMS
with a transform time step and so this
looks pretty confusing right and when I
but if you look here you have date 2014
is triangle 2013 is a circle and the
different systems are the different
colors I think you can see that the
no-till is here CT we've got org six
here and and they org three over here in
general the circles and it's it's a
little clearer in corn than in and in
soybean but the circles are on the lower
part and the triangles are up further in
the graph above zero axis now what we
tried to do here was because we observe
just looking at sheer fungal counts on
plates we knew that there were major
differences between years we know that
there were differences in temperature
not only the the mean temperature but
the timing or the the pure easa T of the
temperature but also water right so what
we tried to do here was create a
covariance matrix that we could
transform the data with to account for
the time factor since we knew it was a
factor I don't know if I don't think it
worked really I mean it worked okay but
but there's better ways to do that and
this there's a new implementation of
time to which explicitly addresses this
so time series and repeated measures and
and so Gregg Capra so who wrote this
program's come is gonna come to my lab
next week and we're gonna work on this
because in he's doing this right now in
human microbiome systems where you have
many individuals who all start off with
a different microbiome and you give them
a treatment and they all move like the
microbiomes move but they're not all
sort of coalescing as a single one and
so that's where that this the knee
for doing this came from but I think in
Ag science we have a real need for this
as well so hopefully in the next few
weeks we'll be able to create a
covariance structure that we can use to
control for the things that we know have
changed especially over times of time
and weather so if we just look straight
at abundances and and and code this this
data differently we actually doing it
differently with the PCA analysis so
where we don't we had to use n MVS
because of the way we did the
transformation of the data but this is
just a break artist distance matrix
represented in PCA
PCA and and the difference is here we
have spray and no spray so the CT spray
and no spray is here nt spray and no
sprays here and spray knows we're kind
of all jumbled on top of each other here
the organic six here again spray no
spray jumbled on top of each other and
here's the organic three over there when
I saw this I was very excited because I
thought wow that's really great after 26
years of management of these systems we
could see really clear like distinct
microbial communities that have been
that have developed over our consistent
differential management of these systems
I
oh I generally don't like drawing
circles around things because I'm like
hey what does that mean but we have
statistics to back that up so that's why
that's why I did this so pretty clear
that we have distinction among among the
systems but no clear distinction among
whether spray has an effect this D and I
look at these a lot but I don't know if
you see but time if we coated this by
time you'd see 2013 and 2014 2013 2014
so you can kind of see that differential
in there and so hopefully when we apply
better statistics to this will maybe be
able to consolidate those those data
clouds a little bit better and and have
a better understanding of how each
individual plot or each individual plant
yeah
changes when we applied glyphosate so I
feel like we're we're not drilling in
well enough here so we we did per manova
I like I like using permit over for the
sort of complex models like this the soy
is on top and the corn is on the bottom
and really the take-home message is that
the system is significant and the year
is significant the sampling date meaning
before spray or after spray is
significant and I'm not sure how much
faith I put in this interaction term
here this is pretty consistent among
crops and this data is is I mean these
same exact factors are what we see when
we look at our other locations which
were in Mississippi and Illinois my what
my graduate student sent me of the
permit over for the bacterial stuff this
morning and and he's showing some some
of the same results but some things are
different and it might be that the
bacteria are actually responding more to
too
both system and glyphosate application
but that will be some other another talk
okay so what can we do what can we do
with this data we could so this is the
change in abundance of the made the
major tax of the change in abundance in
response to glyphosate application so
what you see here are a wide variety of
organisms that both increase increase or
decrease in relation to spray so the
weekend night we can place organisms on
this plot that are identified down to
the genus level because we use that
variant calling approach where we're not
relegated to picking a particular OTU
name from from a database and so in the
case of you know we have Fusarium this
is a species of Fusarium that that
increased and we also see some Fusarium
that decrease and so really what what
we're seeing is no general response to
glyphosate application but most likely
if these are actually responding to the
glyphosate that there's differential
response and there's some other evidence
in the literature that that may actually
be the case that you might have bacteria
and fungi that are resistant or not
resistant based on the sensitivity of
that of that gene in those Shakima
Cassatt pathway so conclusions there no
clear positive or negative impacts of
five-state application and the presence
of the Roundup Ready gene on the
likelihood of Fusarium being being
present in the corn was not was not
clear either it really looks like
there's there's not a strong impact of
that the culturing data suggests that
some organisms may Co occur as such
is she serious macro Femina and some may
be antagonistic like Fusarium so the
sequencing data suggests that the
overall fungal diversity among the
systems is not significantly different
but the structure of the community is
different so there's the the overall
diversity is not is not different and
with the with the tools that we're using
right now we can't discern whether
there's an effect of glyphosate but
these results suggest to the best of
that weekend that there is no effect of
glyphosate on the microbial community so
we're going to be working on the
repeated measures to refine this
analysis so where do we go from here
let's see let's see so Detrick is
working on network analysis and this
isn't it this is an example from this
paper Detrick actually has has a paper
out in which he did this type of network
analysis with on a on a different study
but he is he's going to apply these two
different types of network analysis like
a glow a global analysis which would
take into consideration all of the
interactions between the organisms that
are identified in any particular sample
and we could imagine this as we may see
networks that break out into nodes that
are that are representative of either
crops or systems we're not sure how
that's gonna gonna look right now but we
would we would imagine it would be
something sort of disjointed like this
the other type of network analysis which
we want to look into is this pair wised
pairwise analysis where you create
minimal networks that then have very
specific rules for how o to use or
organisms fit into the network so in
this in this case here and this gets at
this ho occurrence question this is a
this is a an example of where there's a
rule if there's a bacteria yeah and in a
in a Pseudomonas they
this flavor bacterium will be present so
basically it's saying out of all the
data you know if there's these two
organisms this other organism is always
going to be present and we want to do we
want to look specifically at some of
those questions too to get at potential
antagonists for crop diseases and we
think we may be able to pick them out of
datasets like this and the fact that we
have a culturing project that goes right
along with this we have all the isolates
in hand so once we get the genotypes we
could go back and screen the actual
organisms so we've done a little bit of
this already this is my postdoc Brian
Keppler we actually started this project
after we started doing the sampling on
the main project but we finished this
beforehand and this is where we said
okay now if we have organisms that are
like varying their response to our
management some are going up some are
going down maybe we can get a handle on
how these cropping systems are affecting
these organisms by sort of drilling in
to one organism where we know a lot more
about the genetic diversity so in this
case we're interested in this organism
mehta rhythm which is an anthem of
pathogenic fungi and we're particularly
interested in it because it kills bugs
and we've been working with it a little
bit as a bio control for organic systems
looks kind of like Trichoderma in that
case and so what what Ryan did was he
targeted nine low-side that are involved
in meta regime mating type and we went
in and out of out of these these soils
that were collected from the from the
field went in and cloned bar-coded
indexed and sequenced these nine
different different low-side and what we
were able to do from that was determined
that there were that there were two
major clades of matter is 'i'm riper
roberta STI present so we have we
identified two major clades
what we have here is is this is the same
data it's just coded differently
this is clade one and this is clade -
this is a minimal spanning Network for
unique micro satellites so what this
what this is is these ot use are always
associated with these the thicker the
line the stronger the Association and
the thinner the line the weaker the
Association there's there's actually
tiny spotted line there and what we're
looking at in the top half of this what
we're looking at is the the size of the
node is how many ot use we collected
that that fall into that that node and
so it's the actual abundance and then
the the pie chart in there is how those
OTS were distributed among soybean corn
or alfalfa and so what you can see is
that clade 1 and clade to respond very
differently to the different to these
different crops so or somewhat
differently there's there's some that
that are some bow to use that are
dominated by a corn some that are
dominated by soybean if we look on the
lower half we're looking at those at the
system and there you can see differences
as well so in in this in this case some
the these ot use are are in this case
preferentially found in organic six and
here they're evenly distributed so what
this is telling us is that even within I
mean this if we sequence the I TS of
this that iridium it would tell us it's
the same exact organism yet at a much
finer scale we can see that that
different mating types of this single
organism are responding differently to
both the system and the crop
so overall I would say that our farming
state our you know a farming systems
management it does influence microbial
community structure and and in some
cases our broad ways of identifying
these organisms may be like clouding our
ability to really look at the fine the
fine tuned effects of our management
decisions and I think ultimately you
know our goal isn't to be able to
identify an organism the the reason we
want to do that is so we can monitor
these organisms so we can see how when
we make decisions in the field when we
when we make a decision that's going to
be a long-term decision for how we
manage this field we want to be able to
monitor these organisms closely enough
so we can see if they are being affected
if they're resilient to change if they
are functioning the way we want them to
so in the end we're really trying to
design tools that allow us to assess the
the agro-ecosystem
and make recommendations that that
provide resilience and sustainability of
the long term so with that that this is
a team of folks that helped in this
project
Stephanie r-word from University of
Maryland graduate students and postdocs
and then a bunch of folks from USDA in
Beltsville yeah that's it
[Applause]
you continue to do this I'm thinking of
long-term experiments people don't even
if I round up for one year or two years
we keep doing it over decades right yeah
there's anyone looking into long-term
yes well one of the things we tried to
do here was to compare fields like the
organic fields had never had quite to
say before and I didn't really get into
this that much but the organic fields
never had life never had never seemed
like to say and the conventional fields
had seemed glyphosate for 20-something
years so it's so in terms of
experimental design we were kind of
stepping back in history and saying okay
here are these examples they're already
set can we start to determine
differences between them in our other
locations we had fields that had been in
undergunned er management glyphosate for
15 years or so and
fields that were just transitioned out
of like hey those are those are very
very different
it's it's very hard to set up an
experiment like that but it but you
might have to look at systems that are
already existing you know to get those
learnt long-term effects but glyphosate
has been around since the 70s
so there's I'm sure there's examples of
this I think Cornell has examples of
long term with and without glyphosate
application I'm not sure
thanks for the patience I'm really
excited to see what your soil that music
because your expression is actually a
perfect design words idea that we
continuous 20 years of like station
versus not what would be isn't it
possible that you have a mishmash all
bacteria in life is a resistance
initially it being a whole lot of GMO
that had that trade it was initially
isolated yes yeah and then submitted for
pretty good old yeah look for the
resistance and I maybe look to see right
right so we're thinking we're thinking
about that and we went into this so I
have a whole another presentation on the
nitrogen fixation with in the soybean
groups and if you saw in the micro plot
map there were some micro plots I didn't
talk about that said nan Naja lating and
there so we had a whole nother
complement to this experiment and
instead of doing the meta to note we're
doing that some of that but what we did
was we isolated the rhizobia from the
nodules of the sprayed and non sprayed
round of ready plants and the and the
isoline plants and we're planning on
look in doing specific PCR basically to
to sequence those genes from the
different isolates to look for the
resistant and the non-resistant one and
we would basically do correlation
analysis there but the I think the
metagenomic analysis might I mean that
would be great and a lot of information
it might be overkill to get at that one
question and very expensive you know for
the amount of samples that we had so
we're thinking of getting isolates like
some thousand isolates or something like
that and just starts sequencing
the the the peru vape phosphate synthase
gene you know probably yeah so yeah I'm
thinking along the same lines but yes
it's not directly something you talk
about in your pot but I'm just curious
because you'd probably know better than
anybody the answers so with anything
that dose makes the poison right and
when we spray glyphosate onto plants
it has surfactants in it and thing or
things that make it stick to lead we
spray it right on the leaf we make sure
it sticks on the leaves so it kills
those things or not but it's not getting
taken up through the soil so is there
data on what is it the actual
concentration of glyphosate in the soil
even at the time of application let
alone like a week later Dewey's there
yeah and then for what period of the
year we do have a concentration of
legislating the soil that would because
this is a competitive inhibitor so it
needs to be at a high enough
concentration to have effect so for what
period of the year would it it receive
the concentration that the bacteria
would even see it yeah right
so there is data on the excitation rate
and we specifically did there was I to
call it like the indirect effects of
glyphosate application because you're
applying it to the plant and you're
affecting the microbes and that's like I
think a neat aspect of this in just in
general that it's all of this any
treatment effect is transmitted through
a plant xylem
there's information on it plants leak a
lot of glyphosate the surfactants stay
or some of them stay and I forget what
the exact number was but it was it was
it was in the tens percent of the actual
applied concentration and and it does
stay in the rhizosphere and that paper
like there's a paper I can give you the
reference later but the one of the
papers well it's all reported so you can
see one of the papers that I put up here
that talked about the stoichiometry of
glyphosate addresses that issue and
specifically specifically how much of
the product gets transformed into
breakdown products because that's
another issue because not only is
glyphosate a poison but it's breakdown
product that is created in the plan as
as a way of detoxifying it is itself a
toxin but interestingly enough more to
unicellular yes for breakdown product
and um but but yeah that's a that's a
very interesting question because it is
like a it's a pulse and a select
selection that will then fade and the
half-life of glyphosate the molecule
itself is like under two weeks I think
in the in the soil itself unless it's
mixed with something then you have a
whole different thing but it's if I mean
if you look at it looks like great
microbial right so it doesn't when
they've done labeling studies it doesn't
stick allow around for a long time but
you do get that pulse so the susceptible
bacteria probably succumbing to it at
least in short apology research on this
are a lot of ibuprofen pathogens are
actually the application it increases
resistance plant from a boring business
but further out from some of the faculty
sacrifice you mentioned it increases
there
there's actually more disease so it
depends on the lifestyle of fungus as
well is that what that direction is we
find the state but I was curious you
start out your discussion about health
yeah is there any intention to actually
look at symptomology and both Fusarium
and and macro Femina would lend
themselves very well because they both
cause very pronounced fruit ice in both
the soybean and right and and so the
numbers and things are great but it
would be interesting to see are you
getting more rude by creating rice so as
you probably know it's very difficult to
assess that and when it takes a lot of
times yeah it's not difficult
yeah but we we had a pathologist out in
our fields and they were like there's
not a lot here at all so so we generally
don't have cheese areum and macro Femina
as a problem in Maryland in a way I'm
thinking maybe no on the other side of
the farm is very sandy this section here
is pretty clay actually there's a hold
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu